Okay, it's about time we pointed out that there
are traits that aren't very heritable. Meaning that they
don't have a high heritability. For example, monozygotic twins
can easily be discordant with regards to religious belief. This
touches back more on what we discussed in lesson
one, where we first introduced the idea of traits. And
we discussed the idea of a learned versus innate
trait. In this case we're talking about a lower heritability,
meaning that it's more of a learned trait. It
has more to do with your environmental factors, such
as which culture a person might be raised in.
So in other words the low concordance rate of religious
belief between a monozygotic twins results in a lower
heritability. So let's think about it again on our
scale of heritability. Religious belief would be down here
because the variation we see in our population of people
who believe in different things has very little to do
with any kind of genetic factor at all. It's all based
on how this person was raised, where as the other
end of the spectrum we have one of the highest heritabilites
for eye color. Because this is largely controlled by your
genetics. The environment has almost nothing to do with this trait.
And then we could have a trait somewhere in the middle.
Like lung cancer, which we know can be heritable due to
genetic factors. But in the human population, we
see a lot of variability in this trait.
Due to environmental components, such as cigarette smoking.
So remember, in our journey to better understand complex
traits. When we use our twin studies to
determine or estimate an amount of heritability. We're
much better off following up genetically on those
traits that appear to have a larger genetic component.
Than those that don't.